quand j'arrive je vois qu'elle est
caméras dans le prétoire je découvre la
chose mais je me dis quelle aubaine
évidemment on est toujours curieux de
savoir la vérité mais ce qu'on veut
avant tout c'est du spectacle nous
sommes pas dans un film de fiction dans
un show télévisé nous sommes dans une
des plus difficiles entreprises humaines
veuillez lever la main droite et dire je
le jure
voilà moi je me trouvais là
j'avais Sartori en face on vous a
demandé de m'éliminer de la société ici
dans cette pièce tous les extrêmes de
l'être humain le pouvoir politique a
intérêt à ce que les caméras n'entre pas
dans les prétoirs parce que ils
craignent semble-t-il un sou d'un regard
ou un excès de sens critique de la
justice la Cour a décidé de répondre non
et de vous acquitter
[Applaudissements]
tout ce que vous voudrez que les avocats
du 21e siècle que les magistrats du 21e
siècle apprendront à se tenir devant une
caméra l'audience c'est levée se procès
est terminé merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la justice est-elle un spectacle comme
un autre les caméras ont-elles leur
place dans les salles d'audience c'est
un débat qui agite depuis longtemps le
monde judiciaire et celui des médias la
télévision pousse pour que les choses
évoluent mais la magistrature de son
côté frêne pour que les tribunaux
restent des sanctuaires aujourd'hui en
France la situation est confuse les
journalistes ont réussi à mettre un pied
dans la porte ils obtiennent
ponctuellement des autorisations pour
filmer des procès le culte de l'audimat
risque-t-il de rendre la justice sexy au
détriment de la sérénité des débats
Gaston Dominici reste sans faiblesse et
devant lui cette controverse sur la
caméra dans les prétoirs est anciennes
elle date des années 50 avec le procès
de Gaston Dominici accusé du meurtre de
trois touristes anglais
rien de marquant n'est sorti de ce
nouvel acte de l'affaire qui hante tous
les esprits et que suivent minute par
minute 120 journalistes avec leur caméra
leur téléscripteurs et leurs vélos les
audiences ont été fortement perturbées
par cette commune médiatique à l'issue
du procès en 1954 il a été décidé de
bannir appareil photo et caméra des
tribunaux pour ne plus nuire à la
sérénité des débats
et les passions
avant l'affaire Dominici les audiences
pouvaient être filmées en France le
procès du maréchal Pétain en 1945 et
l'un des premiers à avoir été captés par
une caméra et voici que Pétain entre
dans la salle de la première chambre
trois petites salles pour ainsi grands
procès
cette même année 45 des responsables du
Troisième Reich sont également jugés
devant un tribunal international à
Nuremberg cette fois encore les
audiences seront filmées le cinéaste
John Ford en charge du tournage laissera
l'histoire 25 heures de bandes pour un
procès qui a duré 1 an
[Musique]
en 1961 à Jérusalem le procès du SS
adolfeichmann est filmé dans son
intégralité
il est retransmis sur les chaînes
étrangères car Israël ne possède pas
encore la télévision
[Musique]
les autorités israéliennes
entendaient donner à ce procès une
diffusion maximum et donc tous les jours
une résumé d'une heure du procès était
fait et envoyé à Londres d'où il était
ensuite
renvoyé dans les différentes chaînes de
télévision on est à l'époque de la
télévision naissante c'était pas encore
le média masque il est devenu donc
donner une publicité maximum pour
montrer au monde que les Juifs qui
s'étaient fait
exterminés étaient maintenant ceux qui
étaient en mesure de juger leurs
assassins d'hier
madame monsieur bonjour regardez cette
image c'est finalement celle de la
démocratie celle de la justice
en France après l'interdiction de 1954
il faudra attendre le jugement de clause
Barbie en 1997 pour qu'un procès soit à
nouveau filmé
[Musique]
à l'origine de cette décision Robert
Badinter alors garde des sceaux il fait
voter une loi qui autorise la captation
des débats non pas pour une diffusion
télévisée mais pour constituer les
archives de la justice pour garder une
trace
[Applaudissements]
cette matière me paraissait absolument
nécessaire il fallait faire des archives
et enregistrer par conséquent des procès
mais pas pour les montrer immédiatement
pour que la mémoire judiciaire soit
conservée la proximité de l'affaire
Barbie m'a donné l'occasion de faire
passer la loi qui est intervenue parce
que
la République le Premier ministre était
sensible au fait il fallait conserver
les archives de ce qui était le premier
procès des criminels contre l'humanité
en France on savait l'importance de
cette affaire donc j'ai pu pour le
procès Barbie ce n'est pas vrai c'était
à l'occasion du procès Barbie
dans la foulée de la loi Badinter seront
enregistrés pour l'histoire les procès
du miliciens Paul Touvier en 1994 et du
secrétaire général de la préfecture de
Gironde Maurice Papon trois ans plus
tard au-delà des procès des criminels de
guerre Robert Badinter aurait voulu
filmer la justice quotidienne pas pour
la télévision mais toujours pour les
archives
je pense qu'il est tout à fait
indispensable pour la connaissance d'une
société de voir comment elle juge et pas
seulement dans les grandes heures
judiciaires pas seulement les grands
procès qui en eux-mêmes sont historiques
mais le traitement du justiciable
ordinaire en flagrant délit à l'époque
en comparais je suis immédiate des
petites affaires correctionnelles je me
disais il faut absolument qu'on les
saisissent
[Applaudissements]
pour la première fois en France des
caméras de télévision filent un procès
qui à l'inverse de celui de Klaus Barbie
sera rapidement diffusé en 1991 Daniel
Carlin a donc obtenu une dérogation à la
loi de 1954 il a pu filmer pour la
première fois pour la télévision un
procès d'assise dans son documentaire il
montre le jugement d'une affaire simple
celle d'un garçon de 20 ans accusé
d'avoir tué le père de sa petite amie un
homme violent tout ce que nous avons
fait être
pendant la garde à vue être présent dans
le cabinet du juge d'instruction être
présent pendant le procès c'est illégal
simplement je crois que ça correspond à
une volonté du garde des Sceaux de
l'époque c'est-à-dire pierre Arpaillange
et du garde des soins actuels leur
inhalet de voir dans les conditions
qu'on pourrait qualifier d'idéal
qu'est-ce que ça donne
[Musique]
maître Tardy avocat de la défense alors
jeune commis d'office hésite un temps
puis conseillé à son client d'autoriser
Daniel Carlin à le filmer présentant
l'avantage qu'il pourrait tirer de la
présence de la caméra avec des parents
qu'il aime et avec une Sylvie van
kopenone plus forte
j'ai fini par accepter parce que d'abord
c'est tentant de participer à ce genre
de
d'aventure le mot est un peu trop fort
pas d'expérience de d'être un des
vecteurs d'explications de la justice
à la télévision et
la deuxième raison c'est que un des
confrères que j'avais consulté m'avait
dit bah bien sûr qu'il faut dire oui
parce que toute façon tu verras tout le
monde va bien se tenir dans cette
affaire donc ça peut être que profitable
à tout le monde
cette intention c'est l'intention de
tuer moi je ne la vois pas j'ai plaidé
trois quarts d'heure à peu de choses
près et
Carlin nous avait prévenu moi il
l'avocat général en disant maximum je
garde 10 minutes à quart d'heure et
l'avocat général a pris le parti de
faire des réquisitions adaptées au
format télévisé
et
moi j'ai pas prise partie là parce que
c'est quand même
très risqué
si on connaît le résultat à la fin on se
gêne pas mais là c'était ça bloody c'est
un vrai procès vous défendez un vrai
client qui va faire des vraies années de
prison est-ce qu'on peut dire que la
caméra a eu une influence quelconque sur
l'issue de ce procès moi je suis
absolument convaincu
que ça a eu une influence
même le verdict le montre on a quand
même un verdict qui est particulièrement
modéré
un verdict en effet Clément l'accusé
necopra que de 50 prisons
dans la foulée du film de Daniel Carlin
des journalistes commencent à solliciter
des dérogations pour filmer des
audiences il contacte directement les
tribunaux qui avant d'accepter
consultent à leur tour la Chancellerie
au final des centaines d'autorisation
sont accordées chaque année sans grande
cohérence presque exclusivement pour des
procès en correctionnel
en 2004 Dominique Perben alors garde des
sceaux décide de clarifier la situation
et lance une réflexion sur le couple
justice image
journaliste magistrats et avocat planche
sur cette question sous la présidence
d'une juge Elisabeth Linden
nous avons après de longs mois de
travaux et de multiples auditions
conclut à la nécessité
d'ouvrir les prétoirs les salles
d'audience aux caméras mais de ne le
faire que si un certain nombre de
conditions très strictes étaient
respectées
parce que les risques qu'il ne faut pas
se le cacher sont importants et par
conséquent il faut les limiter au
maximum
la commission Linden conclut donc à la
nécessité d'ouvrir les tribunaux caméras
mais avec des garde-fous une captation
intégrale des débats et pas de diffusion
en direct des procès
malgré ses précautions des voix se sont
élevées contre les conclusions du
rapport Agnès tricouart avocate à la
Ligue des droits de l'homme en est une
farouche opposante
a trouvé une espèce de solution qui est
absolument
j'allais dire débile et monstrueuse mais
je le maintiens débile dans le sens où
elle n'a aucune force éthique et elle ne
se
elle ne se justifie en rien qui serait
qu'il y ait des caméras qui filment de
façon neutre et objective et que le film
serait sans auteur
c'est 1984 c'est la caméra de
surveillance c'est Orwell c'est à dire
que c'est un c'est un délire de
surveillance du procès qui permettrait
d'en avoir un compte rendu neutre
évidemment la réalité de faire un film
ça n'est pas celle-là
les membres de la commission Linden ont
travaillé pendant 6 mois pour rendre un
rapport de 80 pages qui restera
finalement l'être morte il ne sera
appliqué par aucun garde des sceaux
les conclusions du rapport Linden elles
sont très intéressantes mais elles sont
objectivement inapplicables je ne
connais pas une société de production un
journaliste qui accepterait les
conditions posées par rapport à Linden
interdire les plans de coupe les gros
plans
préconisés que la diffusion des débats
et de leur intégralité interdire une
coupure publicitaire ça semble être des
conditions qui ne sont pas acceptables
dans les dans les médias actuellement
alors certes c'est compliqué je ne vais
pas nier la complexité des
préconisations et de leur mise en oeuvre
mais en même temps il faut savoir ce que
l'on veut je pense que si l'on ne prend
pas des mesures de protection
des victimes par exemple si on ne prend
pas des mesures sur les conditions de
diffusion
et bien tous les risques que nous que
nous avons évoqué se trouvant ce
réaliseront auront la possibilité de se
réaliser
en 2008 l'un des plus hauts magistrats
de France Laurent Lemelle aujourd'hui
premier avocat général à la Cour de
cassation revient à la charge sur le
sujet en faisant l'éloge de la diffusion
des procès sur le petit écran pour leurs
vertus pédagogiques
je crois que la justice française
fonctionne beaucoup mieux quand le dire
en général
et je pense qu'il serait bien qu'elle se
montre tel qu'elle est réellement c'est
à dire dans son exercice quotidien et de
ce point de vue là les caméras dans les
prétoirs c'est-à-dire
l'enregistrement au fait de rediffusion
rapide
d'un certain nombre d'audience me paraît
être de nature à la fois à montrer aux
Français ce qu'est la justice et à les
convaincre que la justice qui est rendue
oordo est rendu dans de bonnes
conditions si filmer la justice c'est
donner une bonne image de la justice
alors là on est vraiment face à un
problème politique majeur
c'est à dire que si filmer la justice
c'est faire de la com pour remonter
l'image de la justice dans le moral des
troupes et dans le moral des Français
alors on est dans un exercice qui est
complètement dénaturé parce que la
justice a plein de problèmes qui ne sont
pas résolus la justice doit faire face à
des manques d'effectifs à des procédures
expéditives à une inhumanité de plus en
plus grande qu'on voudrait masquer en
donnant une bonne image de la justice
donc l'enjeu politique de filmer la
justice est extrêmement important il ne
suffit pas de donner des assurances des
cahiers des charges non
la mission de la justice et ce qu'elle
est rechercher la vérité et à partir de
là formuler le cas échéant une
condamnation prononcer l'équipement
c'est pas un lieu de spectacle or vous
ne pouvez pas ne pas l'utiliser comme
spectacle télévisuel d'une qualité
supérieure à ce que nous avons dans
certains feuilletons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les États-Unis le pays où la caméra est
reine là-bas elle a fait son entrée dans
les prétoirs depuis plus de 20 ans de
nombreux États comme la Floride ou la
Californie autorise la captation et la
diffusion des débats mais les Américains
sont allés plus loin encore en 1991
Steven Bril crée une chaîne de
télévision dédiée à la retransmission
des procès en direct court TV
très peu d'états autorisé les caméras
dans les prétoirs
un par un pour qu'ils acceptent de
tenter l'expérience
mon argument était de leur dire plutôt
que d'avoir des conférences de presse
organisées par les avocats sur les
marches du palais
ou des tabloïdes relatant les parties
les plus sensationalistes d'un procès
le meilleur moyen pour montrer aux gens
la réalité de la justice
c'est de la filmer
et c'était une bonne idée
[Musique]
chroniqueur judiciaire aujourd'hui
enseignant communication à l'Université
de New York il est un adversaire acharné
de la caméra dans les tribunaux
[Musique]
des personnes sont des savent que la
liberté de la presse fait partie du
premier amendement de la Constitution
je suis sûr que Steven real était animée
de bonnes intentions lorsqu'il a fondé
courtevie il croyait sincèrement qu'il
allait éduquer les Américains en
diffusant des procès
mais la chaîne est tombée assez vite
dans le travers de la télévision
commerciale beaucoup de gens la
regardaient et comme un procès c'est
très ennuyeux les dirigeants ont été
très vite obligés d'en faire un
divertissement
[Musique]
voici le procès le plus célèbre de
l'Histoire capté par la caméra de courbe
TV celui de Jay Simpson ce joueur de
football américain accusé de meurtre en
1995 un procès interminable perturbé au
quotidien par les journalistes plus de
100 millions de téléspectateurs ont
suivi le verdict dans cette affaire la
machine judiciaire n'a obéi qu'à une
seule loi celle des médias
c'était un événement télévisuel
incroyable aux Etats-Unis le pays entier
s'est arrêté quand le verdict a été
annoncé
le président Clinton arrêté de
travailler pour regarder la télévision
et dans tout le Pentagone on s'est
arrêté dans tous les bureaux
tout s'est arrêté
a été tellement altéré par la présence
des caméras que le verdict semblait
totalement inapproprié pour ce procès
des doutes subsistent encore
la justice a-t-elle vraiment été rendue
dans cette affaire
Judy clueger et juge à New York elle a
déjà été filmée pendant des procès
qu'elle présidait dans cet état après
une phase d'expérimentation les
tribunaux ont limité l'accès des caméras
de télévision auprès toi
[Musique]
les médias viennent quand ils sont
intéressés par une affaire
ils ne sont pas toujours attirés par
celles qui informerait le mieux le
public
histoires fortes surtout des crimes tout
ce qui fait de l'audience
alors oui je suis favorable à l'entrée
de la caméra dans les prétoirs dans le
cadre de ce que la loi prévoit mais je
reconnais que ce qui amène les
journalistes dans les tribunaux ce ne
sont pas les cas les plus intéressants
du point de vue pédagogique
judiciaire américain de vrais gens
viennent participer à cette émission
pour qu'une vraie juge arbitre de vraie
litiges et madame la juge est devenu une
star du petit écran les audiences sont
tournés dans les studios de télévision
c'est l'heure de la justice réalité
[Applaudissements]
sur les écrans américains dans divorce
courte des couples viennent se déchirer
à la barre et pour la caméra déballe
leur histoire d'adultère devant la juge
et des millions de téléspectateurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la question première est ce qu'il s'agit
de faire plaisir téléspectateurs est-ce
qu'il s'agit de faire de donner
satisfaction à l'amateur d'émotions
intenses à la faveur de sa
représentation sur l'écran non il s'agit
d'un procès il s'agit d'une épreuve il
s'agit pour la justice comme je me cesse
de le répéter d'arriver à accéder de
serrer aussi pas être possible la vérité
pas de réussir le spectacle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un corps décomposé a été retrouvé hier
soir en contrebas du village de
spelloncato en Haute-Corse la victime a
dans Mazari était porté disparu depuis 7
mois il aurait été tué le 9 décembre
2001 par Patrick sartory un homme déjà
condamné pour meurtre ce reportage du 90
minutes intitulé cour d'assises a été
diffusé en 2007 sur M6 grâce à une
dérogation accordée par le président du
tribunal le réalisateur Olivier pigueti
a pu suivre l'intégralité des débats qui
ont duré une semaine les principaux
acteurs de ce procès ont accepté d'être
filmés à visage découvert Patrick
sartory accusé du meurtre Gisèle
également sur le banc des accusés pour
non dénonciation de crime
Michel Huyette le président du tribunal
et les avocats maître martial qui défend
Patrick sartory et maître hospital pour
la famille de la victime
pourquoi des personnes impliquées dans
une histoire de meurtre accepte-t-elle
d'être filmées comment vivent-elles la
présence de la caméra pendant des
audiences 4 ans après le procès Gisèle a
accepté d'expliquer comment elle avait
vécu cette médiatisation
[Musique]
je pensais que ça allait peut-être avoir
plus un côté négatif que positif et
après en avoir discuté donc même avec
Olivier et surtout mon avocat
on en a pensé que ça allait peut-être
équilibrer les choses si j'ai accepté
c'est pour plusieurs raisons d'abord
c'est que je crois qu'on voit apparaître
chez de très nombreux magistrats une
envie de plus en plus forte de montrer
ce que l'on fait c'est à dire que on
s'est rendu compte au cours des
dernières années que la justice
intéresse de plus en plus de plus en
plus de gens en parlent il y a de plus
en plus d'émissions télévisées il y a
des articles dans les journaux souvent
sans qu'on puisse nous vraiment
participer au débat et l'une des façons
de participer au débat c'est selon moi
de montrer ce que l'on fait à partir du
moment où quelqu'un accepte la caméra
à quelques niveaux qu'on soit
est-ce qu'on le fait
par volonté de se montrer est-ce qu'on
le fait par volonté pédagogique j'y
crois pas trop est-ce qu'on le fait
parce qu'on pense qu'on y a un intérêt à
un moment donné
je suis persuadé que chacune des parties
à un moment donné pense
qu'elle y a intérêt
Olivier pigueti le réalisateur revient
au tribunal de Bastia pour expliquer le
dispositif mis en place pour son
tournage
alors voilà dans cette salle
on était quatre éléments extérieurs
c'est à dire il y avait moins bien sûr
mais deux collègues cameraman et
l'ingénieur du son
voilà moi je me trouvais là
j'avais Sartori en face qui en ayant me
faisait des petits souris
et j'avais un collègue ici à nos
collègues là et dès qu'il y avait des
interruptions de séances en décroché
tous ces caméras et on partait pour
faire des interviews d'un côté ou de
l'autre on a mis un micro ici qu'on a
glissé là bien noir j'avais demandé bien
noir pour pas qu'on voit qu'il y a un
micro-ondes avait glissé un micro ici
noir aussi
à Sartori là-bas et les deux avocats qui
principaux donc la défense plus c'est de
celui de sartorique qui avait des micro
sur eux dans une autre pour ce tournage
Olivier piggetti en effet obtenu une
autorisation exceptionnelle de la part
des avocats ils ont accepté d'être
enregistré pendant leur conversation en
aparté avec leurs clients un élément qui
a posé problème à la diffusion
elle était toute nue
il me semble maintenant
et ce que je retiendrai de ce procès moi
c'est pas les caméras
c'est paradoxalement le micro
c'est à dire que je me rends compte et
moi j'ai essayé d'être très prudent on
n'est jamais assez mais sur la maîtrise
absolue
que nous avons de cette parole là pas la
parole qui consiste à plaider ou à
s'exprimer dans un procès mais la parole
vis-à-vis de ce que nous défendons qui
doit rester à mon avis
secrète et ça dans le reportage par
moment
on a été la limite il manque comme il
respire et le président s'en est rendu
compte que des avocats acceptent de
montrer comme ça comment ils discute
avec leurs clients de la stratégie
adoptée j'avoue que moi ça m'a fait
réagir très fortement parce que c'est la
première fois que je le voyais de façon
si net et si crue par la suite je sais
que certains de leurs collègues leur ont
tapé sur les doigts à cause justement de
la présence de ces micros parce qu'ils
estimaient qu'ils avaient tronqué un peu
ce devoir de de confidentialité qu'ils
ont avec leurs clients mettons une
graine redonnons de l'espoir verdict
d'espoir mesdames et messieurs dans
l'humain dans l'inhumain toujours de
l'humain votre verdict le prouvera je
suis persuadé que la présence de la
caméra et les micros dans une salle
d'audience et dans une salle de cours
d'assise
oblige les uns et les autres à faire des
efforts même si on a la conscience très
vite que on est plus espionner entre
guillemets mais en tout cas sa police
tout le monde il faut absolument que
nous sachions pour juger il faut d'abord
savoir ce qui s'est passé dans tous les
cas ça n'approcher de la vérité même si
on cherche à faire semblant pendant
quelques minutes ou quelques demi-heure
pour être autrement que ce que l'on est
on tient pas longtemps dire très vite le
caractère le tempérament la façon de
siéger enfin la façon d'agir
professionnellement reprendre le dessus
et je crois que même si on veut tricher
un peu quelques minutes on arrête très
vite alors si je dis pas qu'au moment de
se gratter l'oreille on n'hésite pas un
peu parce qu'on sait qu'il y a une
caméra mais ça s'arrête là quoi et je ne
peux pas tout lire qu'on dise des choses
quand même qu'on dise que moi je
méritais d'être frappé
alors à ce compte là on a qu'à aller
jusqu'à encore plus loin et à dire
peut-être c'était moi qui demandait les
coups non tant qu'on y est
quand même quand on voit le film il y a
certaines il y a certains passages où on
se rend compte qu'au départ il est un
petit peu
un président à charge un petit peu alors
qu'un président doit être à charge à des
charges il doit être
équitable et en fait au début on se rend
bien compte que quand même il est plus
en charge qu'à des charges et je pense
que le fait qu'il y a eu les caméras ça
l'a un petit peu calmé dans ses ardeurs
et peut-être aussi qu'à moi ça m'a donné
peut-être un peu de confiance aussi de
savoir que la caméra était là et que ça
allait donner une justice plus équitable
à la question numéro 7 qui vous concerne
la Cour a décidé de répondre non et de
vous acquitter
[Applaudissements]
la cour à la majorité absolue a décidé
de condamner Monsieur Patrick sartory à
la peine de 10 années d'emprisonnement
l'audience c'est levée se procès et
terminé merci
je pense que mes clients ne comprenaient
pas pourquoi le verdict est pu être
aussi Clément voilà ne le comprenez pas
et le reportage illustrant cela
dans des millions de spectateurs les
choquer encore plus
d'où la question est-ce que si on
l'avait pas fait le verdict ut était
différent que l'on trouve le verdict
sévère ou indulgent il faut s'interroger
par rapport à la faire par rapport aux
circonstances par rapport à la
personnalité des accusés à la
personnalité de la victime mais c'est
certainement pas la présence des caméras
qui a eu un impact sur la décision
finale de non ça je ne pense pas du tout
finalement le parquet fera appel Patrick
sartory sera condamné à 12 ans
d'emprisonnement et Gisèle
définitivement acquitté ce documentaire
n'a été diffusé qu’après le jugement en
appel soit six années après les faits en
Corse ou Gisèle vit encore aujourd'hui
le film d'Olivier pigetti a fait
énormément de bruit pas simple de
reprendre une vie normale avec ce film
je n'aurais jamais droit à l'oubli
alors que moi c'est ce que je souhaitais
donc qui est ce procès que je sois
quitté bien sûr et qu'on passe à autre
chose et c'est vrai qu'à cause de ce
film
je n'aurais pas ça je n'aurais jamais le
droit à l'oubli ici dans cette pièce
tous les extrêmes de l'être humain c'est
fascinant c'est extraordinaire on a tout
ce qu'on ne veut pas être mais tout ce
que tout un chacun pourrait faire elle
ne fera sans doute jamais mais donner la
mort à quelqu'un c'est absolument
c'est à causevable pour tout le monde
c'est un concevable on est tous pourtant
capables sans doute un jour de pouvoir
faire ça donc on se retrouve ici à
l'extrême de l'être humain c'est juste
moi ça me fascine dans tous les cas je
pense que on est tous fascinés par ça
et ça ça peut faire un bon film et ça ça
peut faire un beau film ça peut faire un
mauvais film aussi
ça peut faire un mauvais film quand on
n'a pas saisi l'être humain qui va
au-delà de ce geste voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean-Xavier de l'estrade est
documentariste lui aussi il a réalisé 5
films sur la justice il a reçu de
nombreux prix dont un Oscar en 2002 pour
un coupable idéal un documentaire qui
retrace le procès d'un jeune noir
américain
[Musique]
aux États-Unis son film qui montre les
dérives du système judiciaire a eu un
retentissement énorme
[Musique]
en 2009 il s'intéresse à un autre procès
en France cette fois celui de Véronique
courgeot la mère accusée dans l'affaire
dite des bébés congelés
[Musique]
tous les ingrédients étaient réunis pour
en faire l'un des faits divers les plus
médiatisés de la décennie un couple aisé
en apparence sans histoire une accusée
Véronique courgeot qui reconnaît les
infanticides après les avoirniers un
mari blanchi qui soutient sa femme sans
relâche enfin cette histoire brise un
tabou celui du déni de grossesse
sa tige vraiment ma curiosité je me
renseigne je vais sur internet sur plein
de trucs et je finis mais en fait oui il
faut que ça traite de plein de domaines
afin de sujets qui me passionnent et
donc il faut ce serait intéressant d'en
faire un film
mais jean-Xavier de l'estrade va vite
déchanter en France filmer un procès
d'assise reste très compliqué
contrairement aux États-Unis pour la
faire Courjault il demande une
dérogation au tribunal qui lui accorde
mais ça bloque au niveau de la
chancellerie et finalement le
réalisateur n'obtient pas l'autorisation
de filmer
disons que c'est trop sensible pour
qu'on puisse laisser des caméras rentrer
dans le prétoire et filmer un procès
dont on ne connaît absolument pas
l'issue continuité dans la durée pour
contourner cette interdiction il met en
place un dispositif lourd et coûteux il
décide de faire une reconstitution
exacte du procès sous la forme d'une
fiction
pour cela il prend en note l'intégralité
des 9 jours de débat et recrutent des
comédiens qui prononceront les mêmes
mots que Véronique Courjault et les
autres personnes du procès
avez-vous eu l'occasion de déplacer ses
bébés à d'autres moments que lors de
votre déménagement cette reconstitution
a été diffusée en décembre 2009 sur
France 3 six mois après la condamnation
de Véronique courgeot à 8 ans
d'emprisonnement finalement jean-Xavier
de Lestrade ne regrette pas de ne pas
avoir pu filmer le procès et d'avoir eu
recours à la fiction autant au départ je
me sentais frustré de pas filmer le
procès autant aujourd'hui je
ma position elle est beaucoup plus
nuancée je me dis
si tu étais terrible pour elle si on a
pu filmer le procès j'ai voulu trouver
des réponses dans la dynamique des
interrogatoires j'ai voulu trouver des
réponses qui collent avec
avec l'image de moi que je découvrais
qu'on me donnait
et
plein assez serrés sur elle pendant le
procès il y a beaucoup de gens qui ont
regardé ça pour regarder le visage de la
tueuse quel visage a-t-elle comment
comment parle-t-elle de ça et quand on
scrute on scrute l'horreur ou le diable
on scrute celle que l'on a envie de
détester on scrute le monstre et là on
ne donne pas de prise à ça on ne peut
pas parce que voilà c'est une comédienne
qui joue c'est pas vernis crojot c'est
quelqu'un d'autre donc on entend mieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
28 janvier 2010 Palais de justice de
Paris pour le jugement de l'affaire
Clearstream il est 8h du matin
l'audience ne démarre que dans trois
heures les journalistes de télévision
sont déjà là ils veulent pour leur
caméra la meilleure place pour ne rien
perdre de l'événement judiciaire de
l'année ici on est bien loin du
documentaire en longueur sur la justice
il va s'agir de ne rien rater pour la
grand-messe des JT
Dominique verdayan est l'un des derniers
chroniqueurs judiciaires à la télévision
française avec ses mots il va devoir
transmettre ce que la caméra n'aura pas
eu le droit de capter du procès
à partir du moment où on est on est puni
et que même si l'audience est publique
elle n'est en tout cas pas filmable
évidemment vous avez la multiplication
maintenant pas les petits pains mais des
caméras à l'extérieur avec ce risque que
nous vivons depuis des années nous qui
suivons les process c'est ce risque de
faire un procès parallèle donc notre
vigilance c'est dans les propos qui sont
tenus par les prévenus par les partis
civiques par les avocats ça ne soit pas
en contradiction et pareil pour ce que
nous allons dire nous évidemment dans
nos commentaires que ce ne soit pas en
contradiction avec ce qui s'est passé à
l'intérieur du réseau
se correspondant d'une chaîne espagnole
et la lui aussi pour couvrir les Pilogue
de la saga clear stream dans son pays il
aurait pu entrer dans la salle
d'audience avec sa caméra en Espagne la
plupart des procès peuvent être filmés
pour le journal télévisé
pour les citoyens c'est enrichissant de
voir ce qui se passe à l'intérieur des
tribunaux dans le cas de Clearstream on
a perdu beaucoup d'informations
essentielles même si les journalistes de
presse écrite restituent les paroles des
changées au cours du procès c'est bien
on ne voit pas comment les uns et les
autres se sont comportés et on ne voit
pas leurs gestes donc oui c'est
important de filmer
les stars du jour arrivent au tribunal
[Musique]
pas un mot pas un regard pour les médias
la plupart des journalistes vont passer
le procès à l'extérieur de la salle
d'audience et prendre leur mal en
patience
les nouvelles technologies ont conquis
les prétoirs plus rapidement que la
caméra depuis peu les journalistes
entrent dans le tribunal avec téléphone
et ordinateur portable ils peuvent ainsi
relater l'audience minute par minute via
des sites comme Twitter ils envoient
également alors collègues rester à
l'extérieur des informations en live sur
le procès
j'ai ma collègue qui est à l'intérieur
et qui dit au fur et à mesure ce qui se
passe qu'elle elle entend et quand moi
j'ai une question éventuellement besoin
de confirmer une source AFP ou une
source d'un autre journaliste je renvoie
un texto et elle me confirme si elle est
capable de me confirmer parce que elle
elle a entendu est-ce qu'on peut donner
à l'antenne sans faire de bêtises et là
à l'instant elle m'envoie un texto en me
disant que maintenant c'est Dominique de
Villepin que Villepin va pas tarder à
tomber moi je me mets en position direct
et comme ça dès qu'il tombe sans
attendre midi on peut faire un direct
avec le jugement dès que j'aurai la
confirmation par ma collègue à
l'intérieur donc là je pars me mettre en
position
le jugement vient enfin de tomber les
journalistes espèrent tous obtenir la
petite phrase percutante de Dominique de
Villepin et des ténors du barreau et à
trois personnes qui sont sortis
[Musique]
la justice
a été rendu
après plusieurs années d'épreuves
mon innocence a été reconnu
les dessinateurs de procès sont les
seuls à pouvoir capter l'émotion des
justiciables
news qui couvre ce jugement pour Charlie
Hebdo a saisi l'expression de Dominique
de Villepin
il a laissé rien rien transparaître il
était plutôt rigide c'était plutôt
ni souriant ni particulièrement
visage sans rien
ok deuxième
Dominique de Villepin a du patienter
dans son direct Dominique verdaillon
dispose d'une minute 30 pour transmettre
ce qui s'est passé en trois heures de
procès pour lui si demain la caméra
entre dans le prétoire tout est possible
le meilleur comme le pire
un montage un procès montage rigoureux
sur la longueur de ce qui s'est passé à
un procès je pense que ça peut avoir un
côté entre guillemets pédagogique
l'image du jour de ce qui s'est passé au
procès de l'aveu du du de la cuisine qui
craque dans le box ou de la victime qui
s'effondre dans le vainqueur du soir
je suis pas sûr que ça soit la bourre
pour demain et que ça soit
à quoi il faut se diriger
on retrouve le correspondant espagnol
David Picasso après le procès clear
stream en Espagne filmer les procès est
un enjeu démocratique
et n'est-ce pas
la liberté la démocratie il y a un peu
plus de 30 ans on a voulu apporter de la
transparence après des années de
dictature passé de l'ombre à la lumière
tantôt c'est pour ça qu'on a ouvert les
institutions comme le Parlement et les
tribunaux caméras
je veux assister sur un point ce n'est
pas parce que l'on filme les procès que
la justice perd en qualité
elle ne sait pas dégradée en Espagne et
ce serait la même chose en France en
revanche ceux qui ont tout à gagner de
la présence de la caméra ce sont les
médias et les citoyens
[Musique]
décembre 2008 Santos miraciera un
supporter de l'Olympique de Marseille et
jugé dans un tribunal espagnol pour des
violences dans un stade à Madrid
[Musique]
ces débats ont pu être filmés pour les
télévisions nationales et françaises
comme la loi espagnole lie autorise
[Musique]
pour sa défense miraciera recruté un
avocat espagnol pour plaider devant la
cour et un français très médiatique pour
plaider devant les caméras
[Musique]
l'image de Maître Collard aux côtés de
miraciera sur le banc des accusés est
trop belle elle fera le tour des
journaux télévisés
[Musique]
quand j'arrive et que je vois qu'elle
est caméras dans le prétoire je découvre
la chose mais je me dis quelle aubaine
là il nous donne tant pis pour eux
tant mieux pour nous l'occasion vraiment
si on est habillé si on sait y faire
d'instrumentaliser la scène
son client avait écopé de trois ans de
prison ferme sous la pression médiatique
et diplomatique il sera finalement
libéré sous caution Maître Collard a
imaginé pour les caméras la phrase qui
fera le tour de toutes les rédactions
j'ai fabriqué une formule qui a provoqué
beaucoup de réactions
j'ai dit
Santos c'est le premier détenu politique
de l'histoire du sport
c'était énorme j'espère qu'on va arriver
à
le délivrer de cette situation de
prisonnier politique du sport c'est le
premier prisonnier politique de
l'histoire du sport est-ce que j'ai été
choisi pour mon talent d'avocat ou pour
mon talent médiatique je crois que les
deux sont liés puisque aujourd'hui
qu'on le veuille ou non il y a dans
certaines affaires
inévitablement par la position que
l'accusé va occuper sur l'échiquier
médiatique une nécessaire
instrumentalisation et une inévitable
exploitation médiatique on plaide devant
les médias comme on plaide devant les
juges
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
14h50 sur France Info c'est l'heure du
droit d'info avec karine Duchochois
Karine bonjour du bon des accusés à ceux
de Radio France Carine Duchaussoy l'une
des acquittés d'Outreau a fait du chemin
et l'anime quotidiennement cette
chronique dans laquelle elle défend les
droits des auditeurs dans cette terrible
histoire de pédophilie les acquittés ont
été les victimes d'une instruction
bâclée et de médias qui n'ont pas hésité
à bafouer la présomption d'innocence
jusqu'au revirement à l'audience de
l'accusatrice Myriam Badaoui pour karine
Duchochois ce moment aurait dû être
filmé quand Myriam Badaoui revient sur
ses déclarations se retourne nous dit à
tous on a rien fait vous n'avez rien
fait j'ai menti je suis une menteuse à
ce moment-là ce qui a été
ce qu'on a vu comme image au JT c'est
nous qui ressortons en pleurant en
disant c'est fini ça y est elle a dit la
vérité serait permis aussi illustrer ce
moment là en montrant Myriam Badaoui qui
se retourne et qui nous dit à tous on
n'a rien fait voyez ça ça aurait plein
d'utilités moi je trouve d'avoir ces
images
une suspicion diffuse règne encore
aujourd'hui sur les acquittés
avaient vu l'image de l'accusatrice les
innocents ces derniers auraient-ils été
définitivement blanchis dans l'esprit
des gens en tout cas pour karine
Duchochois la caméra aurait eu une
fonction majeure celle de juger jauger
le juge et finalement être l'oeil du
citoyen
filmer le procès ça peut ça va obliger
les magistrats à faire leur boulot donc
ça peut en quelque sorte quelque part
influencer le verdict dans le sens où
ils seront forcément obligés de prendre
tous les éléments en compte à la fois
charge et à des charges et donc ce qui
fait que le jugement rendu sera
peut-être plus juste tout simplement
[Musique]
de ce 17 janvier 2005 à 9h du matin je
pousse la porte du cabinet présidentiel
pour lui annoncer ma démission ce qui
était une surprise une démission
spectaculaire comment on claque une
porte c'était d'autant plus une surprise
pour le président du tribunal de grande
instance de Tours que ça ne se fait
jamais au Canada Laurent LeGac le juge
d'instruction insoumis claque donc la
porte de la magistrature un événement
rarissime il est devenu enseignant
écrivain et acteur à 16h perdus
ce jour-là à l'université France
Télévisions il vient donner un cours sur
les relations entre les médias et la
justice à des journalistes régulièrement
amenés à couvrir des procès comment
réaliser des reportages pour le journal
télévisé sans filmer les audiences
l'information serait-elle mieux traitée
avec une caméra dans les prétoirs le
débat est ouvert
je rencontre et le refus des caméras
comme tout le reste c'est un désir
d'emprise une volonté de contrôle par
une magistrature formée par encore une
fois par une école de haut
fonctionnaires donc d'aussi le pouvoir
on veut on veut que ça reste comme ça on
veut on ne veut pas que le peuple puisse
vraiment contrôler sa justice en même
temps un sujet d'une trente si on
imagine dans un prétoire ça peut être
une vraie catastrophe vu les raccourcis
qui sont faits j'ai rien que par nous
dans les sujets parfois ce serait pas
forcément de
je sais pas il y aurait certainement une
nécessité de condenser enfin de faire
une synthèse parce qu'effectivement on
peut pas laisser une audience défiler se
serait difficile en temps mais il y
aurait une vérité supplémentaire
certainement tu as l'image ça
permettrait par exemple de répondre à la
question qui est une vraie fichu bonne
question c'est combien y a-t-il
d'affaires d'Outreau en France par an
les caméras elles sont partout
aujourd'hui on est filmé partout dans
tout ce qu'on fait dans la rue bon c'est
hyper intrusif on est diffusé partout
sur les téléphones portables sur
Internet et puis c'est vrai que on peut
même filmer ma tendre des blocs
opératoires on peut filmer on rentre
dans l'hôpital on rentre dans les
prisons on rentre et c'est vrai que
la justice pourrait quand même
aujourd'hui
bien en respectant les règles bien
évidemment il y aurait des règles à ne
pas en prendre pour tout à fait qu'on ne
traite pas et auquel on s'intéresse pas
parce que ah bah nous on a pas d'image
à mon avis la peur la le tabou la peur
irrationnelle on peut calme le pouvoir
on va dire les pouvoirs les trois
pouvoirs d'ailleurs législatif exécutifs
et judiciaire la peur irrationalisait
qu'ils ont de la caméra c'est parce que
la caméra dans la symbolique c'est
évident que c'est l'oeil vous voyez
comme comme dans le verre de Victor Hugo
l'œil était un atome et regarder il y a
c'est l'oeil ils ont peur de l'oeil du
peuple sur eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette histoire c'est celle de la caméra
dans les prétoirs c'est aussi celle de
notre justice et celle de nos médias une
saga de plus d'un demi-siècle du procès
Dominici au grand show clear stream la
caméra n'a cessé de faire un pas en
avant un pas en arrière mais elle est
toujours officiellement bonne idée
tribunaux en France jusqu'à quand
il est certain que on va vers une
ouverture plus grande de la justice aux
caméras je n'imagine pas que
en tout cas dans les années à venir je
peux pas me prononcer pour les décennies
à venir mais dans les années à venir je
sens pas un mouvement vers une ouverture
absolue des salles d'audience aux
caméras parce qu'après pourquoi
s'arrêter ça à l'audience on peut aussi
filmer ce qui se passe dans le bureau du
juste des enfants Joseph à familial etc
faut arrêter d'avoir peur de tout mon
avance avec notre temps ça se fait dans
d'autres pays ça se fait ça se passe
très bien et moi j'ai pas peur de cette
justice à l'écran à la télévision
de voir si le pouvoir de la télévision
la séduction de la télévision seront
suffisants pour faire entrer les caméras
dans les tribunaux en France ou ailleurs
je ne vois pas cette interdiction de
fait qui existe depuis
depuis plusieurs décennies
durer très longtemps qu'est-ce qui va se
passer demain
on arrêtera pas
la dictature du ventre on arrêtera pas
la dictature de l'émotion d'autant plus
que on ne fait rien pour l'arrêter
d'autant plus que les barrières qui
pourraient en Diguer le déferlement de
l'émotion c'est-à-dire l'école
l'apprentissage de l'histoire la
réflexion les débats intelligents
n'existent plus donc moi je suis
persuadé que
les caméras seront dans les prétois
les assassins seront des artistes et le
le crime
occupera de plus en plus le champ de nos
occupations et de nos distractions
à qu'il est beau l'assassin de papa
[Musique]